oh hi I'm Elle Woods and for my
admissions essay I'm gonna tell all of
you at Harvard why I'm gonna make an
amazing lawyer wait a minute which one
is the real Elle Woods as president of
my sorority I'm skilled and commanding
the attention of a room and discussing
very important issues all those opposed
to changing please say aye the verdict
is in Kim Kardashian just one Halloween
you can just be someone different you
can offend whatever you want she
definitely did just that the 39 year old
aspiring lawyer poked fun at the haters
dropping this epic recreation of Reese
Witherspoon's character Elle Woods
Harvard admissions seen from Legally
Blonde on Instagram the internet was
shook I was shocked
Kim nailed Elle's looks rocking her
signature blonde do down and up showing
off her figure in pink and green
sequined bikinis I'm able to recall
hundreds of important details at the
drop of a hat
hey Elle do you know what happened on
Days of Our Lives yesterday why yes
Marco I do
once again we join pink in the search
for identity as you know all while
sporting chunky Tiffany jewelry and a
fluffy pink pen of course I'm really
freaking out
Kim also shared a series of
behind-the-scenes pics from the shoot
legal jargon in everyday life I have
checked Risa didn't respond with that
but a repost of Kim's video on the
Graham writing Elwood's forever
[Music]